the real question is why does chat GPD
work how is it possible to encapsulate
you know to successfully reproduce all
these kinds of things in natural
language
um you know with a you know a
comparatively small he says you know a
couple hundred billion you know weights
of neural net and so on and I think that
uh you know that that relates to kind of
a fundamental fact about language which
uh you know the the main the main thing
is that I think there's a structure to
language that we haven't kind of really
explored very well as kind of the
semantic grammar I'm talking about about
um about language I mean we kind of know
that when we when we set up human
language we know that it has certain
regularities we know that it has a
certain grammatical structure you know
noun followed by verb followed by noun
adjectives Etc et cetera et cetera
that's its kind of grammatical structure
but I think the thing that tragic is
showing us is that there's an additional
kind of regularity to language which has
to do with the meaning of the language
Beyond just this pure you know part of
speech combination type of thing and I
think the uh the the kind of the the one
example of that that we've had in the
past is logic and you know I I think my
my sort of uh uh uh kind of picture of
how was logic invented how was logic
discovered uh it really was the thing
that was discovered in its original
conception it was discovered presumably
by Aristotle who kind of listened to a
bunch of people orators you know giving
speeches and this one made sense that
one doesn't make sense this one and you
know you see these patterns of you know
if the uh you know I don't know what you
know if the uh if the Persians do this
then this does that
Etc et cetera et cetera and what what
Aristotle realized is there's a
structure to those sentences there's a
structure to that rhetoric that doesn't
matter whether it's the Persians and the
Greeks or whether it's the cats and the
dogs it's just you know p and Q you can
abstract from this the the details of
these particular sentences you can lift
out this kind of formal structure and
that's what logic is that's a heck of a
discovery by the way logic you're making
me realize now
yeah it's not obvious the fact that
there is an abstraction from natural
language that has where you can fill in
any word you want yeah is a very
interesting Discovery now it took a long
time to mature I mean Aristotle had this
idea of syllogistic logic where there
were these particular patterns of how
you could argue things so to speak and
you know in the Middle Ages part of
Education was you memorize the
syllogisms I forget how many there were
but 15 of them or something and they all
had names they all had mnemonics like I
think Barbara and celerant were two of
the the mnemonics for the the syllogisms
and people would kind of this is a valid
argument because it follows the Barbara
syllogism so to speak and it took until
um you know with uh George boole to kind
of get beyond that and kind of see that
there was a a level of abstraction that
was beyond the this particular template
of a sentence so to speak
um and that's you know what's
interesting there is in a sense you know
you know Chachi BT is operating at the
Aristotelian level it's essentially
dealing with templates of sentences by
the time you get to Bool and Boolean
algebra and this idea of you know you
can have arbitrary depth nested
collections of ants and ores and Knots
and you can resolve what they mean
um that's the kind of thing that's a
computation story that's you know you've
gone beyond the pure sort of templates
of natural language to something which
is an arbitrarily deep computation
but the thing that I think we realize
from from chat GPT is you know Aristotle
stopped too quickly and there was more
that you could have lifted out of
language as formal structures and I
think there's you know in a sense we've
captured some of that in in you know
some of what what is in language that
there's there's a there's a lot of kind
of little calculator little algebras of
of what you can say what language talks
about I mean whether it's I don't know
if you say uh
I go from place a to place B Place B to
place C then I know I've gone from place
a to place C if a is a friend of B and B
is a friend of C it doesn't necessarily
follow that a is a friend of C these are
things that are uh you know that there
are if if you go from from place a to
place B Place B to place C it doesn't
matter how you went like logic it
doesn't matter whether you flew there
walked there swam there whatever you
still this transitivity of of where you
go is still valid and there are there
are many kinds of kind of features I
think of the way the world Works uh that
are captured in these aspects of of
language so to speak and I think what
what chat gbt effectively has found just
like it discovered logic you know people
are really surprised it can do these
these logical inferences it discovered
Logic the same way Aristotle discovered
logic by looking at a lot of sentences
effectively and noticing the patterns in
those sentences but it feels like it's
discovering something much more
complicated than logic so this kind of
semantic grammar I think he wrote about
this
um
maybe we can call it the laws of
language I believe you call or which I
like the laws of thought yes that was
the title that George boole had for his
for his Boolean algebra back in 1830 but
yes I was a thought yes that was what he
said
all right so he thought he thought he
nailed it with blue in algebra yeah
there's more to it yeah it's a good
question how much more
is there to it and it seems like one of
the reasons as you uh imply that the
reason gbt Works chat GPT works is that
uh
there's a finite num number of things to
it yeah I mean it's discovering the laws
in some sense GPT is discovering this
laws of semantic grammar that underlies
language yes and what's sort of
interesting is in the computational
universe there's a lot of other kinds of
computation that you could do they're
just not ones that we humans have cared
about and and operate with and that's
probably because our brains are built in
a certain way and you know the neural
Nets of our brains are not that
different in some sense from the neural
Nets of of uh of a large language model
and that's kind of and so when we think
about and you know maybe we can talk
about the small but when we think about
sort of what will AIS ultimately do
the answer is insofar as AIS are just
doing computation they can run off and
do all these kinds of crazy computations
but the ones that we sort of have have
decided we care about are there is this
kind of very limited set
that's where the uh reinforcement
learning with human feedback seems to
come in the more the AI say the stuff
that kind of interests us the more we're
impressed by it
so you can do a lot of interesting
intelligent things but we're only
interested in the AI systems
when they communicate human in a
human-like way you ask about human-like
topics yes well it's it's like
technology I mean in a sense the
physical world provides all kinds of
things you know the all kinds of
processes going on in physics only a
limited set of those are ones that we
capture and use for technology because
they're only a limited set but we say
you know this is a thing that we can
sort of apply to the human purposes we
currently care about I mean you might
have said okay you pick up a piece of of
rock you say okay there's a nice
silicate it contains all kinds of
silicon I don't care then you realize oh
we could actually turn this into a you
know semiconductor wafer and make it
microprocessor out of it and then we
care a lot about it yes um and it's it's
you know it's this thing about what do
we you know in the evolution of our
civilization what things do we identify
as being things we care about I mean
it's like you know when when there was a
little announcement recently of the
possibility of a high temperature
superconductor that involved you know
the element lutetium which you know
generally nobody has cared about and you
know it's kind of um but suddenly if
there's this application that relates to
kind of human purposes we start to care
a lot so given your thinking that GPT
may have discovered inklings of laws of
thought do you think such laws exist can
we Linger on that what's your intuition
here oh definitely I mean the fact is
look the the logic is but the first step
there are many other kinds of calculi
about things that uh we consider you
know about sort of things that happen in
the world or things that are meaningful
well how do you know logic is not the
last step you know what I mean so
because we can plainly see that that
thing I mean if if you say here's a
sentence that is syntactically correct
okay you look at it and you're like you
know the happy electron you you know
eight
I don't know what some something that it
just it you look at and it's like this
is meaningless it's just a bunch of
words it's syntactically correct the
nouns and the verbs are in the right
place but it just doesn't mean anything
um and so there clearly is some rule
that there are rules that determine when
a sentence is has the potential to be
meaningful that go beyond the pure parts
of speech syntax and so the question is
what are those rules and are there
fairly finite set of those rules my
guess is that there's a fairly finite
set of those rules and they you know
once you have those rules you have a
kind of a construction kit just like
this the rules of syntactic grammar give
you a construction kit for making
syntactically correct sentences so you
can also have a construction kit for
making semantically correct sentences
those sentences may not be realized in
the world I mean I think you know the
elephant flew to the moon yeah a
syntactic a semantically you know we
know we have an idea if I say that to
you you kind of know what that means but
the fact is it hasn't been realized in
the world so to speak so semantically
correct perhaps there's things that can
be imagined with the human mind no uh
things that are
consistent with both our imagination and
our understanding of physical reality I
don't yeah good question I mean it's a
good question it's a good question I
mean I think it is it is given the way
we have constructed language it is
things which which fit with the things
we're describing in language it's a bit
circular in the end because you know you
can and and the and the the sort of
boundaries of what is physically
realizable okay let's take the example
of motion okay motion is a complicated
concept it might seem like it's a
concept that should have been figured
out by the Greeks you know long ago but
it's actually really pretty complicated
concept because what is motion motion is
you can go from place a to place B and
it's still you when you get to the other
end right you you take an object you
move it and it's still the same object
but it's in a different place now even
in ordinary physics that doesn't always
work that way if you're near a
space-time singularity in a black hole
for example and you take your teapot or
something you don't have much of a
teapot by the time it's near the
space-time Singularity it's been
completely you know deformed beyond
recognition but so that's a case where
pure emotion doesn't really work you
can't have a thing stay the same but so
this idea of motion is is something that
sort of is a slightly complicated idea
but once you have the idea of motion you
can start once you have the idea that
you're going to describe things as being
the same thing but in a different place
that sort of abstracted idea then has
you know that has all sorts of
consequences like this transitivity of
motion go from A to B B to C you've gone
from a to c
um and that's so that level of
description you can have what are sort
of uh inevitable consequences they're
inevitable features of the way you've
sort of set things up and that's I think
what this sort of semantic grammar is
capturing is things things like that and
I you know I think that it's a question
of what does the word mean when you say
I go from I move from here to there well
it's complicated to say what that means
this is this whole issue of you know is
pure motion possible Etc et cetera et
cetera but once you have kind of got an
idea of what that means then there are
inevitable consequences of that idea
but the very idea of meaning it seems
like there's some words that become
um
it's like there's a latent ambiguity to
them I mean it's the word like
emotionally loaded words like hate and
love
right it's like what what are they what
do they mean exactly like what
um so especially when you have
relationships between complicated
objects we seem to take this kind of
shortcut descriptive shortcut of to
describe like right object a hates
object B what's that really mean right
well words are defined by kind of our
social use of them I mean it's not you
know a word
in computational language for example
when we say we have a a construct there
we expect that that construct is a
building block from which we can
construct an arbitrarily tall tower so
we have to have a very solid building
block and you know we have to it turns
into a piece of code it has
documentation it's you know it's a whole
it's a whole thing but the word hate you
know the documentation for that word
well there isn't a standard
documentation for that word so to speak
it's a complicated thing defined by kind
of how we use it when you know if it
wasn't for the fact that we were using
language I mean so so what is language
at some level language is a way of
packaging thoughts so that we can
communicate them to another mind can
these complicated words
be converted into something that a
computation engine can use right so so I
think the answer to that is that that
what one can do in computational
language is Define make a def make a
specific definition and if you have a
complicated word like let's say the word
eat okay you think that's a simple word
it's you know animals eat things
whatever else but you know you do
programming you say this function eats
arguments which is sort of poetically
similar to the animal eating things but
if you start to say well what are the
implications of you know uh the function
eating something you know does it can
can the function be poisoned well maybe
it can actually but um uh you know if
there's a tight mismatch or something in
some language but but you know in what
how far does that analogy go and it's
it's just an analogy whereas if you use
the word eat
in a computational language level you
would Define there isn't a thing which
you anchor to the kind of natural
language concept eat but it is now some
precise definition of that that then you
can compute things from but don't you
think the analogy is also precise
software eats the world don't you think
there's a
there's something Concrete in terms of
meaning about analogies sure but the
thing that sort of is the first Target
for computational language is to take
sort of the ordinary meaning of things
and try and make it precise make it
sufficiently precise you can build these
towers of computation on top of it so
it's kind of like if you start with a
piece of poetry and you say I'm going to
Define my program with this piece of
poetry it's kind of like that's that's a
difficult thing it's better to say I'm
going to just have this boring piece of
prose and it's using words in the
ordinary way and that's how I'm
communicating with my computer and
that's how I'm going to build the solid
building block from which I can
construct this whole kind of
computational Tower so there's some
sense where if you take a poem and
reduce it to something computable you're
going to have very few things left so
maybe there's a bunch of human
interaction that's just poetic
aimless nonsense
well that's just like recreational like
hamster in a wheel it's not actually
producing anything well I I I think that
that's a complicated thing because in a
sense human linguistic communication is
there's one mind it's producing language
that language is having an effect on
another mind yeah and the question of
there's sort of a a type of effect that
is well defined let's say where where
for example it's very independent of the
two minds that the it doesn't you know
that there there's communication where
it can matter a lot sort of what the
experience of of um uh of one mind is
versus another one and so on
yeah but uh
what is the purpose of natural language
communication
well I think I think versus so
computation computational language
somehow feels more amenable to the
definition of purpose it's like yeah
you're given two
clean representations of a concept and
you can build a tower based on that is
is natural language the same thing but
more fuzzy what well I think the the
story of natural language right in the
the that's the great invention of our
species we don't know whether exists in
other species but we know it exists in
our species it's the thing that allows
you to sort of communicate abstractly
from like one generation of the species
to another you can you know there is an
abstract version of knowledge that can
be passed down it doesn't have to be you
know genetics it doesn't have to be you
know you don't have to Apprentice the
next species you know the next
generation of birds to the previous one
to show them how something works yeah
there is this abstracted version of
knowledge that can be kind of passed
down now that you know it relies on it
still tends to rely because language is
fuzzy it does tend to rely on the fact
that you know if we look at the you know
some ancient language that where we
don't have a chain of translations from
it until what we have today we may not
understand that ancient language
um and we may not understand you know
its Concepts may be different from the
ones that we have today we still have to
have something of a chain but it is
something where we can realistically
expect to communicate abstract ideas and
that's you know that's one of the big
big roles of a language I think you know
in in um
uh it's you know that that's been this
this ability to sort of concretify
abstract things is what what language
has provided do you see natural language
and thought as the same the stuff that's
going inside your mind
well
that's been a long debate in philosophy
it seems to be become more important now
when we think about
how intelligent GPT is
whatever that means whatever that means
but it seems like the stuff that's going
on in the human mind seems something
like intelligence in this language well
we call it intelligence yeah we call it
well yes and so you start to think of
okay what's the relationship between
thought
the language of thought the laws of
thought the laws of the words like
reasoning
and the laws of language and how that
has to do with computation which seems
like a more rigorous precise ways of
reasoning right which are Beyond human I
mean much of what computers do human
humans do not do I mean you might say
humans are a subset yeah presumably yes
hopefully yes the the yes right you know
you might say who needs computation when
we have large language models large
language models can just you know
eventually you'll have a big enough
neuron that it can do anything but
they're really doing the kinds of things
that humans quickly do and they're
plenty of sort of formal things that
humans never quickly do for example I
don't know I you know you can some
people can do mental arithmetic they can
do a certain amount of math in their in
their minds I don't think many people
can run a program in their minds of any
sophistication it's just not something
people do it's not something people have
even thought of doing because just it's
kind of a it's kind of not you know you
can easily run it on a computer when
another arbitrary program yeah aren't we
running specialized programs yeah yeah
but if I say to you there's a turing
machine yeah you know tell me what it
does after 50 steps and you're like
trying to think about that in your mind
that's really hard to do it's not what
people do I mean well in some sense
people program they build a computer
they program it just to answer your
question about what the system does
after 50 steps I mean humans build
computers yes yes yeah that's right but
they've created something which is then
you know then when they run it it's
doing something different than what's
happening in their minds I mean they've
outsourced that that piece of
computation from something that is
internally happening in their minds to
something that is now a tool that's
external to their minds so whether we're
humans to you didn't invent computers
they discovered them
they discovered computation which they
invented the technology of computers
this the computer is just a
kind of way to plug into this whole this
stream of computation which probably
other are the ways for sure I mean the
the you know the particular ways that we
make computers out of semiconductors and
electronics and so on that's the
particular technology stack we built I
mean the story of a lot of what people
try to do with Quantum Computing is
finding different sort of underlying
physical you know infrastructure for
doing computation you know biology does
lots of computation it does it using an
infrastructure that's different from
semiconductors and electronics it's a
you know it's a molecular scale uh sort
of computational process that hopefully
we'll understand more about I have some
ideas about understanding more about
that but uh you know that's that's
another ins you know it's another
representation of computation things
that happen in the physical Universe at
the level of you know these evolving
hypographs and so on that's another sort
of implementation layer for this
abstract idea of computation so if GPT
or large language models starting to
form
starting to develop or implicitly
understand the laws of language and
thought do you think they can be made
explicit yes
doing Natural Science I mean what is
happening in Natural Science you have
the world that's doing all these
complicated things and then you discover
you know Newton's laws for example this
is how motion works this is the way that
this particular sort of idealization of
the world this is how we describe it in
a simple computationally reducible way
and I think it's the same thing here
it's there are sort of computationally
reducible aspects of what's Happening
that you can get a kind of narrative
theory for just as we've got narrative
theories in physics and so on
do you think it will be
depressing or exciting
when all the laws of thought are made
explicit human thought made explicit I
think that once you understand
computational reducibility it is uh it's
neither of those things because the fact
is people say for example people will
say oh but you know I have free will I I
kind of um you know I operate in a way
that is uh uh you know you you the the
the they have the idea that they're
doing something that is sort of of
internal to them that they're figuring
out what's what's happening but in fact
we think there are laws of physics that
ultimately determine you know every uh
every nerve you know every electrical
impulse and a nerve and things like this
so you might say isn't it depressing
that we are ultimately just determined
by the rules of physics so to speak
um it's the same thing it's at a higher
level it's like it's it's it's a shorter
distance to get from kind of semantic
grammar to the way that we might
construct a piece of text than it is to
get from Individual nerve firings to how
we construct a piece of text but it's
not fundamentally different and by the
way as soon as we have this kind of
level of you know this other level of
description it's kind of it helps us to
go even further so we'll end up being
able to produce more and more
complicated Kinds of Kinds of things
that just like when we you know if we
didn't have a computer and we knew
certain rules we could write them down
and go a certain distance but once we
have a computer we can go vastly further
and this is the same kind of thing you
wrote a blog post titled what is Chad
GPT doing and where does it work we've
been talking about this but can we just
step back and Linger on this question
what what's it what's Chad GPT doing
what are these
um
bunch of billion parameters trained on a
large number of words like why does it
seem to work again is it is it because
to the point you made that there's laws
of language that can be discovered by
such a process is there something well
let's let's talk about sort of the low
level of what chat GPT is doing I mean
ultimately you give it a prompt it's
trying to work out you know what should
the next word be right which is wild
isn't that isn't that surprising to you
that this kind of low level dumb
training procedure can create something
syntactically correct first and then
semantically correct you know the thing
that has been sort of a story of my life
is realizing that simple rules can do
much more complicated things than you
imagine that something that starts
simple and start simple to describe can
grow a thing that is you know vastly
more complex located than you can
imagine and honestly it's taken me I
don't know I've sort of been thinking
about this now 40 years or so and it
always surprises me I mean even for
example in our physics project sort of
thinking about the whole universe
growing from these simple rules I still
resist because I keep on thinking you
know how can something really
complicated arise from something that
simple it just seems you know it seems
wrong but yet you know the majority of
my life I've kind of known from from
things I've studied that this is the way
things work so yes I it is wild that
it's possible to write a word at a time
and produce a coherent essay for example
but it's worth understanding kind of how
that's working I mean it's kind of like
if if it was going to say you know the
cat sat on the what's the next word okay
so how does it figure out the next word
well it's seen a trillion words written
on the internet and it's seen the cat
sat on the floor the cat sat on the sofa
the cat sat on the whatever so it's
minimal thing to do is just say let's
look at what we saw on the internet we
saw you know 10 000 examples of the cat
sat on the what was the most probable
next word let's just pick that out and
say that's the next word and that's
that's kind of what it is at some level
is trying to do now the problem is there
isn't enough text on the internet to uh
for if you have a reasonable length of
prompt to that that Pro that specific
prompt will never have occurred on the
internet and as you as you kind of go
further there just won't be a place
where you could have trained you know
where you could just worked out
probabilities from what was already
there
um you know like if you say two plus two
there'll be a zillion examples of two
plus two equaling four and a very small
number of examples of two plus two
equals five and so on and you can pretty
much know what's going to happen so then
the question is well if you can't just
work out from examples what's going to
happen just no probabilistic for you for
examples what's going to happen you have
to have a model and there's kind of an
idea this idea of making models of
things is an idea that really I don't
know I think Galileo probably was one of
the first people who sort of worked this
out and it's kind of like like you know
I think I gave an example of that little
book I wrote about about Chachi BT where
it's kind of like you know Galileo was
dropping cannonballs off the off the
different floors of the of the Tower of
Pisa and it's like okay you drop a
cannonball off this floor you drop a
cannonball off this floor you miss floor
five or something for whatever reason
but you know the time it took the
Cannonball to fall to the ground from
floors one two three four six seven
eight for example then the question is
can you work out can you can you make a
model which figures out how long does it
take the ball how long would it take the
ball to fall to the ground from the
floor you didn't explicitly measure and
the thing Galileo realized is that you
can use math you can use mathematical
formulas to make a model for how long it
will take the ball to fall so now the
quest question is well okay you want to
make a model for for example something
much more elaborate like you've got this
arrangement of pixels and is this
arrangement of pixels an A or a B does
it correspond to something we'd
recognize as an A or B and you can make
a similar kind you know each pixel is
like a parameter in some equation and
you could write down this giant equation
where the answer is either you know a or
you know one or two A or B
um and the question is then what kind of
a model successfully reproduces the way
that we humans would would conclude that
this is an A and this is a b you know if
there's a complicated extra tail on the
top of the a would we then conclude
something different what is the type of
model that Maps well into the way that
we humans make distinctions about things
and the big kind of meta Discovery is
neural Nets are such a model it's not
obvious they would be such a model it
could be that human distinctions are not
captured you know we could try searching
around for a Titan model that could be a
mathematical model it could be some
model based on something else that
captures kind of typical human
distinctions about things it turns out
this model that actually is very much
the way that we think the architecture
of brains works that perhaps not
surprisingly that model actually
corresponds to the way we make these
distinctions and so you know the the
core next point is that the the kind of
model that's neural net model makes sort
of distinctions and generalizes things
in sort of the same way that we humans
do it and that's why when you say you
know the cat set on the Green
blank even though it never didn't see
many examples of the cat set on the
green whatever it can make a or the
aardvark sat on the green whatever I'm
sure that particular sentence does not
occur on the internet and so it has to
make a model that concludes what you
know it has to kind of generalize from
what it's from the actual examples that
it's seen and so so you know that that's
the fact is that neural Nets generalize
in the same kind of a way that we humans
do if if we were you know the aliens
might look at our neural net
generalizations and say that's crazy you
know that thing when you put that extra
little dot on the a that isn't an a
anymore that's you know that messed the
whole thing up but for us humans we make
distinctions which seem to correspond to
the kinds of distinctions that neural
Nets make so then you know the the thing
that is just amazing to me about chat
gbt is how similar the structure it has
is to the very original way people
imagine neural Nets might work but back
in 1943 and you know there's a lot of
detailed engineering you know great
cleverness but it's really the same idea
and in fact even the sort of
elaborations of that idea where people
said let's put in some actual particular
structure to try and make the neural net
more elaborate to be very clever about
it most of that didn't matter I mean
there's some things that seem to you
know when you when you train this neural
net you know the one thing this kind of
Transformer architecture this attention
idea that really has to do with does
every one of these neurons connect to
every other neuron or is it somehow
causally localized so to speak does it
like we're making a sequence of words
and the words depend on previous words
rather than just everything can depend
on everything and that seems to be
important in just organizing things so
that you don't have a sort of a giant
mess but the thing you know the thing
worth understanding about what is chat
gpg in the end I mean what is a neuron
that's in the end a neural net in the
end is each neuron has a it it's taking
inputs from a bunch of other neurons
it's it's eventually it's going to have
uh it's going to have a a numerical
value it's going to compute some number
and it's it's saying I'm going to look
at the the neurons above me it's kind of
a series of layers it's going to look at
the neurons above me and it's going to
say what are the values of all those
neurons then it's going to add those up
and multiply them by these weights and
then it's going to apply some function
that says if it's bigger than 0 or
something then make it one or an
otherwise make it zero or some slightly
more complicated function you know very
well how this works but it's a giant
equation with a lot of variables you
mentioned figuring out where the ball
Falls when you don't have data on the
fourth floor
um this the equation here is not as
simple as the equation but the 175
billion terms and it's quite surprising
that in some sense a simple procedure of
training session equation can lead to
well I think that good representation of
natural language right the the real
issue is you know this architecture of a
neural net where where what's happening
is you know you've you've you've turned
so neural Nets always just deal with
numbers and so you know you've turned
the sentence that you started with into
a bunch of numbers like let's say by
mapping you know each word of the 50 000
words in English you just map each word
or each part of a word into some number
you feed all those numbers in
and then the thing is going to and then
those numbers just go into the values of
these neurons and then what happens is
it's just Rippling down going layer to
layer until it gets to the end I think
chat gpg has about 400 layers and you're
just you know it just goes once through
it just every every new word it's going
to compute just says here are the here
are the numbers from the words before
let's compute the what is it compute it
computes the probabilities that it
estimates for each of the possible 50
000 words that could come next and then
it decides sometimes it will use the
most probable word sometimes it will use
not the most probable word it's an
interesting fact that there's this
so-called temperature parameter which
you know at temperature zero it's always
using the most probable word that it can
that it estimated was the the most
probable thing to come next you know if
you increase the temperature it'll be
more and more kind of random in its
selection of words it'll go down to
lower and lower probability words thing
I was just playing with actually
recently was the transition that happens
as you increase the temperature the
thing goes Bonkers at a particular you
know sometimes at a particular
temperature I think maybe about 1.2 is
the thing I was noticing from yesterday
actually
um that you know usually it's giving
reasonable answers and then uh at that
temperature with some probability it
just starts spouting nonsense
um and you know nobody knows why this
happens I mean it's it's uh uh and by
the way I mean the thing to understand
is it's putting down one word at a time
but the outer loop of the fact that it
says okay I put down a word now let's
take the whole thing I wrote so far
let's feed that back in let's put down
another word that outer loop which seems
almost trivial is really important to
the operation of the thing and and for
example one of the things that is kind
of funky is it'll give an answer and you
say to it is that answer correct and
it'll say no
and why is that happening right right
why couldn't it do that well the answer
is because it is going one word at a
time sort of forwards and it didn't you
know it it came along with some sort of
chain of of thought in a sense and it
came up with completely the wrong answer
but as soon as you feed it the whole
thing that it came up with it
immediately knows that that isn't right
it immediately can recognize that was a
you know a bad syllogism or something
and uh can see what happened even though
as it was being led down this Garden
Path so to speak it didn't it came to
the wrong place
but it's fascinating that this kind of
procedure converges to something that
forms a pretty good compressed
representation of language on the
internet yeah that's quite right right
no I'm not sure what to make of it well
look I think you know there are many
things we don't understand okay so for
example you know 175 billion weights
it's maybe about a trillion bytes of
information which is very comparable to
the training set that was used
um and uh you know why that why kind of
it sort of stands to some kind of reason
that the number of Weights in the neural
net I don't know where I can't really
argue that I can't really give you a
good uh you know in a sense the very
fact that you know the insofar as there
are definite rules of what's going on
you might expect that eventually we'll
have a much smaller neural net that will
successfully capture what's happening I
I don't think the best way to do it is
probably a neural net I think a neuron
that has what you do when you don't know
any other way to structure the thing and
it's a very good thing to do if you
don't know any other way to structure
the thing and for the last 2000 years we
haven't known any other way to structure
it so this is a pretty good way to start
but that doesn't mean you can't find
sort of in a sense more symbolic rules
for what's going on that you know much
of which will then be you can kind of
get rid of much of the structure of the
neural Nets and replace it by things
which are sort of pure steps of
computation so to speak sort of with
neural net stuff around the edges and
that becomes just a you know just a much
simpler way to do it so then you're on
that you hope will reveal
to us good symbolic rules that make the
need of the neural net less and less and
less right and and there will still be
some stuff that's kind of fuzzy just
like you know that the things that it's
like this question of what can we
formalize what can we turn into
computational language what is just sort
of oh it happens that way just because
brains are set up that way